you were diagnosed with add right and
and like a lot of people say their add
and all this but literally if you would
look at a page in a book or something
like that your attention span would just
what just snap that was that i couldn't
i can't you were dyslexic oh dyslexia
was probably a little bit of it when i
spell like i'll jump i jump letters
right and i don't know how everybody's
got it a little differently i guess
here's the amazing thing in your career
so you moved to miami and because you
you know you're just sort of out there a
mo a talent scout a model talent scout
says hey man i'm going to sign you and
do you think like what do you mean like
like does that come out of the blue yeah
and he puts you away in commercials um
yeah i was i was i was walking around in
miami and this dude comes up to me in
urban outfitters and he's like do you
have representation
what for what and uh i went down there
to kind of try to see what was going on
with modeling but the the woman that i
actually
went down there first kind of just went
like in my eyes she just disappeared you
probably said to yourself in miami at
that point this is not a legitimate
business proposal right yeah it was it
was kind of shoddy since the very
beginning of it but it did make me go
okay well maybe i should go into some of
these uh some of these other agencies
yeah and i did and it worked out and so
all of a sudden the career was really
kind of the career path was chosen for
you you weren't thinking i'll be an
actor but you cast as a dancer in a
video for uh ricky martin right yeah i
actually did that before i started
modeling that was the shebang's
yeah and uh then you do uh ads right gap
um
nautica and stuff and then you start
doing commercials and then that requires
you got to start memorizing lines
reading scripts and things
were you in a panic because of your
learning disability were you like oh
[ __ ] this is where it all ends they want
me but how am i going to learn the lines
yeah and i'm the audition process is
really hard and that in that regard
because you get a bunch of auditions a
day a bunch of pages and so if i wasn't
off book completely
i couldn't look down and like read read
the read the lines i just physically
couldn't do it and uh so it was a it was
a big
learning curve i guess i would say but
at one point i did get a movie and sam
jackson asked him i was like how do you
do it you know because he's i've read
somewhere that he had a speech
impediment yeah um and he was like i
learned the conversation i know what the
conversation is about and it and it
helps them so i i stopped learning lines
and more about what the actual
conversation was about yeah you've even
said in interviews that it'll take you
five times as long to read a script than
most actors but you know the script
really well once you read it because
you're reading it slowly and
thoughtfully and when you hosted
saturday night live you said that was
the most harrowing experience because
you have to read off a cue card yeah uh
you can't sort of memorize i would
almost throw up right now thinking about
it
it was just would you ever do it again i
am going to do it again you know it's
always it's always been uh you know
something that i go okay that was super
hard for me and i have to do it again i
want to do it better but when they asked
you the first time did you sit down with
lauren michaels because i know he'll
bring you in and stuff and you'll talk
did you say them listen i got to be
upfront with you reading off a
teleprompter is probably our cue card is
maybe the worst fear in my life and and
i'm not sure how i'm going to overcome
that or do you just keep quiet and
barrel through it i think i might
brought it up but lauren is such
lauren's such a like a kill is such an
assassin he just he takes any of your
insecurities
and sort of does this weird like jedi
mind tricks and acts like it nothing
like you're gonna be fine kid and and
then you start believing that you're
gonna be fine
and he's just a pro he's just such a pro
that he he makes everybody walk in
because he he has assassins that he's
like don't worry about it they're going
to take care of you and they did do you
have people in your life like an agent
and stuff who say to you listen we don't
want to put you in a bad situation we
don't need this is live television
let's not do this you know right did the
people say oh yeah yeah they're like are
you sure you want to do this right
because what do you need for your honor
roll the [ __ ] movies you're making
are making hundreds of millions of
dollars everybody wants you to be in
their films why humble yourself or why
risk
humiliation you know i don't know you
know i just go if you're ever going to
do it you know you i don't know i'm i'ma
jump off the cliff and figure out how
the parachute works later